hi I'm James Powell this is what's new
on Python 3 we're at PI data at San
Francisco it's Friday August 12 2016
yeah that's very helpful because people
need to actually figure out when that
video was taken especially for something
as timely as this topic now one thing I
also like to do with my talks is to
maybe warm up the crowd a little bit by
just saying hi everyone I'm James oh
very good so that's also it's also kind
of gives me a clue for who's ever seen
me speak before something I like to do
at the beginning of all of my talks and
it's just a nice way to get you guys
warmed up so this talk is called what's
new in Python 3 one thing that I would
say characterizes a lot of the talks
that I've given and I think this is our
20th PI data event so that means this is
the 20th time I've presented in a PI
data conference is the what I pitch as
the idea weeks in advance of the event
and what I actually present on stage
never quite match up because you think
oh this would be a great idea people
really want to hear about that then when
you're actually sitting and putting the
slides together you realize well I don't
know if I'm the right person to present
this or it feels a little bit different
so when I was putting the slides
together I wanted to give you a very
straightforward view of what's new in
Python 3 that said as I began to think
more about the topic and think more
about what it means to give a tutorial
rather than a talk I thought will be
very useful would be to show you how you
could actually determine that yourselves
and how you could give a presentation
like this one of the disclaimers in my
talk is that I am NOT a Python core
developer
I'm not directly involved in the
production of Python 3 I'm a Python 3
user very familiar with the C Python
code base I work with 2 C Python 3 core
developers and I consulted them when
putting together this presentation but
I'm an outsider to this process in many
ways many of you are outsiders to a lot
of the tools that you'll see presented
at this event but that doesn't mean that
you're not able
to participate in this event by giving a
talk by sharing with other people what
you've learned about these these
projects and these tools one thing about
Python 3 or rather one thing about these
kind of talks is that they're actually
pretty easy to put together because you
can refer to material that's online and
I'll show you just some steps for how I
actually put this together without
having to reference other other people's
material there are for this topic or for
many others so a lot of presentations
about what's new in Python 3 what's new
in Python 3 4 3 5 you know specific
topics or laser-focused versions of
what's new and async i/o and Python 3 5
or what's new an async I own Python 3 6
but it's actually pretty easy to put
together a talk like this and I would
tell you the developers of these
projects actually like it when other
people present their work so some of you
in the audience might be heavy users of
pandas and there are a lot of recent
changes to pandas a lot of improvements
and you might say well you know I really
get a lot of value out of using these
improvements in pandas I'd like to give
a talk but I'm not a pandas core
developer you know I don't want Wes to
get angry at me for going up on stage
and maybe slightly miss speaking in my
experience and from from having met the
core developers for all the tools that
you'll see at this event they'd actually
like that and and they're more than
happy to see other people present this
so they're more than happy to help you
out if you email them or if you get in
contact with the people at num focus
we'd be more than happy to connect you
to core developers if you want to give a
talk like this but that's one common
thread that I wanted to inject that's
not actually in the materials itself but
something that I wanted to keep in a in
the forefront of the talk how would you
actually give a talk like this and
that's what I consider to be the core of
the tutorial content for this because
the rest of it is more or less just to
feature parade I'm going to show you a
lot of features in Python 2 or rather a
lot of features in Python 3 that are new
and we'll go through them at a leisurely
pace we might skip over a couple of them
but I think what's more important is how
would you actually be able to keep track
of this how would you actually be able
to give a talk like this and also one
thing that will be very valuable I think
to get out of this tutorial
would be to have more of you in this see
the camera can't see you so this
humongous enthusiastic frankly quite
beautiful audience give more talks like
this and future private events so let's
get started I want to start with a very
simple survey how many of you are still
using Python 2 so almost everybody
raised their hands how many of you are
still using Python 2 by choice 2 or 3 or
4 people raise their hands
so just to drill down on that of the
four people who raise their hands how
many of you are using Python 2 by choice
because there's some library that you
need to use that's not supported in
Python 3 how many of you are using it
because you just think python 3 is going
in absolutely the wrong direction how
many of you using it just because you
haven't had a chance to look into what's
new a python 3 so there seem to be
probably many many other reasons for why
people are still using Python 2 by
choice but I think what we can see is
there's a strong desire for people to
use Python 3 although it may not match
up with what they're actually using in
practice who hears using Python 3 who
hears using Python 3 for work so that
was about about a fifth of the crowd
raise your hand and one or two people
raised their hand for they're actually
using Python 3 for the work so I presume
that the rest of you are using Python 3
in your own research or in your
prototyping or off to the side it's not
part of your production process who's
using a Python greater than 3.5 who's
using a Python greater than 3.4 so the
same people who raised their hands
before so nobody here is using Python
3.5 is anyone using Python 3.6 I'm
probably the only person here who's used
Python 3.6 and it's still a release
candidate it's not an officially
released version yet or at least it's
not it hasn't had its first proper
release yet but you can see that in a
crowd of data scientists the usage of
some of these bleeding-edge versions of
Python it's not it's not going to be
very common who here is using whatever
version of Python was installed with
anaconda and they just really didn't
choose they just installed and that's
whatever it's they're quite quite a few
people and that's a very reasonable
thing to see in an audience of
scientific users and audience of data
scientists you know the the choice
between Python 2 or the choice between
the various versions of Python 3 really
isn't as pressing as a need to
immediately focus on solving your
business problems and so you download
anaconda you installed anaconda like
many people maybe the next time that you
update what version of Python you're use
you probably might not even update it
via Conda you might just wipe away your
anaconda install and reinstall anaconda
from whatever's you know on the
continuum website who here is using
whatever Python was available via
anaconda when they first installed it
never updated it it's still the same
anaconda install never end Conda update
whatever and you know they're just using
whatever they had that's just the tool
that's in front of them okay so nobody
actually raised their hand
I would I would have expected you know
if we ignore some of that pointed
wording here I would have expected a
couple of people to just be fairly
ambivalent or fairly or even you know
totally unconcerned with what version of
Python they're using because for a lot
of people the version of Python is
really not the most pressing thing I got
into a argument or actually I had a
back-and-forth very recently on Twitter
where I was looking at some code that
was written in Python for one of the
poll aggregation websites the Princeton
election website where they aggregate
all the polls and they give a
probability for each of the two
candidates to win and I had looked
through the code because it was in
Python used matplotlib and numpy and I
emailed the author and I said I found a
bug in your code and the interesting
thing about that is and I think the San
Francisco audience might like this the
reason that the author of this code had
never run across the bug was because it
was in a branch where he prints out
information if the other candidate was
leading in the polls which had never
happened and so consistently since even
publishing this information one of the
two candidates and I
say which one but you can guess was
doing much better than the other when I
talked about that on Twitter some people
said well if you look at this code it's
not very good it's like a lot of
scientific code it's just written you
know may have been written ten years ago
was written prior to the author learning
what a context manager is so might have
even been written prior to Python to
four to five and I've never been updated
but the reality of the situation if
you're a scientific user is you labor
under different economics and you're not
being paid to use the latest and
greatest you understand that sometimes
their benefits do that and we'll see
some of the things you can do in Python
3 5 + 3 6 but you're not pressed in the
same way that maybe a software developer
is to adopt the latest in grapes and I
want to say that's that's okay it's I
think I think we need to have an
understanding at least there needs to be
a more nuanced understanding between
people who are on the software
development side and people who are on
the scientific side that scientists
maybe don't care that much about code
quality and that's ok and software
engineers do care a lot about code
quality and there's a reason for that
but there's not there's not a contention
there or there doesn't have to be a
contention there before we dive into
what's new in Python 3 and I'm sure some
of you are just squirming in your seats
to actually figure out what's new in
Python 3 I wanted to correct the title
and the reason I wanted to correct the
title was the ax title here is what's
new in Python 3 except Python 3 was
released in 2008 that was about two
thousand eight hundred and nine days ago
or two thousand eight hundred nine days
ago when I updated this notebook last
night so we're talking about ten years
ago coming up in two years will come up
on the 10th anniversary of Python 3 so I
thought would be kind of silly for me to
come up here and tell you what's new in
Python 3 even though a lot of you using
Python 2 because you've had about 10
years of time to see other people give
that presentation and I want to give you
something that you might not have seen
before but in the same vein if I were to
talk about what's new in Python 3 5
python 3 5 was released in September
last year
so almost 365 days ago almost a full
year ago
and so in the intervening year you might
have seen other presentations about
what's new in Python 3 5 in fact I can
point you in the direction of two good
presentations if you look up era Muir
he's one of the core contributors to sin
PI he has a very nice slide deck online
about what's what you're missing out in
Python 3 and there was a talk last year
at PI data Seattle given by one of the
speakers who will be at this event as
well
Steve dower about upcoming changes in
Python 3 and I believe this was just
very very shortly after the release
either very shortly before very apt very
shortly after the official release of
Python 35 so if I wanted to correct the
title I might say this is what's new in
Python 3 5 and 3 6 except I have to put
a maybe there because the approach that
I'm going to take to show you what's new
in Python 3 5 and 3 6 is going to cover
some changes that are actually still
speculative python 3 6 is still in the
process of being released and some of
the changes that are slated for that are
still speculative when we talk about the
pet process you'll see that it's
possible for apep to be accepted and
then later rejected and so some of the
changes we look at aren't final even
things that are final in the Python
language can be removed later on things
like tuple unpacking in parameter lists
got removed from Python 2 to Python 3
features can be removed so what I'll
show you is a view of what's in Python 3
and 3 5 + 3 6 but not necessarily
everything that's there there is a more
important question than the question
posed in the title and the most
important question I think is how do I
keep up to date what changes in Python 3
the answer I'll give you may not be as
easily generalizable to all the many
different things you have to keep up
with but let's let's since we have a lot
of time we have a long session and I'd
like to get a lot of feedback from you
how many of you update the packages that
you're using whether it's something as
big as Python or as small as you know
one of the small add-ins that you have
maybe something built on top of numpy or
pandas how many of you actually update
any of the package
that you use in your work environment on
more than a yearly basis
only a couple how many of you really
haven't ever bothered to update you mean
you had a deployment environment and you
just stuck with that from when it was
delivered to you and you just keep using
it and there's no real so that's that's
a couple of people how many of you
update pretty religiously you see
there's a new version of pandas I got to
get on them almost nobody only a couple
of people in the back and this is also
not too uncommon now one of the reasons
one of the reasons why that is I think
can help us in this session so how many
of you aren't updated because a lot of
you are not updating very regularly that
or you're already a little tired so your
hands are kind of lagging but how many
of you haven't updated because there's
just too much there's just too much
going on you have to follow all of the
changes in the actual field where you
work and then you have to follow all
these changes at the Python level at the
package level at the operating system
level and after a while you say well you
know I'm running it out of hours in the
day to understand what the latest and
greatest thing is and in many cases
that's distracting me from what I'm
actually being paid to do come on I
phrased that I phrased that so that more
of you should be raising your hands it's
not a it's not an uncommon situation to
be in and so the question is how do you
keep up to date and it's not a very easy
question to answer and it's not
necessarily something to be
generalizable one important disclaimer
for all of this talk and for the answer
I'm going to give you is that I'm not a
core developer I'm not a core developer
of Python 3 or any of the numbers
projects I work with people who are core
developers of these projects I asked
them about this question and about
certain topics here and I want to tell
you what they said but I am relaying the
information they told me there are a
couple of different ways one of the ways
is to follow Python death so some of you
may know that there's a mailing list
called Python def and there's a mailing
list called Python ideas and if you
follow those mailing lists you'll see
most of the public conversation around
changes the Python 3 Python 3 is a very
large the Python 3 core developers is a
fairly large community of people who've
known each other and been working
together very closely for a long period
of time so there are conversations that
do not occur on the mailing list there
are small Sprint's or discussions that
occur off list that are then brought
onto the mailing list for discussion but
the mailing list is actually a pretty
good resource for trying to see the
entire seeing the best snapshot of the
public decision making process it is
definitely true that at PyCon a couple
of core developers might corner Guido in
a room and say this is a change that we
want and they might have a discussion
right there and make a decision right
there without that being something
that's on the mailing list but for the
most part a lot of the major changes or
a majority of the major changes you'll
see are on the mailing list the volume
of the mailing list is pretty big so if
I open this link you'll see nope I'm not
connected to Wi-Fi but volume of the
mailing list is pretty large and what I
have found is oftentimes I get the
emails and I delete them the moment they
hit my inbox just because I don't have
the time to read through a lot of
bickering and back-and-forth about often
times what are very minor changes
unfortunately as with all mailing lists
and all public discussions there isn't a
nice scaling or calibration between the
importance of the topic and how much
people talk about it so sometimes people
talk a lot about things which aren't
very important and then sometimes very
very important and very meaningful
changes only get a little bit of
discussion so it's difficult to follow
along when I asked the core developers
that I know and that I work with about
this topic how do you keep up to date
they all responded followed an analyst
and I said well what if you're a normal
human being and they said well ok
there's other approaches so don't expect
to be following this if you're a normal
human being it's a lot of traffic the
value of the mailing list is sometimes
decisions are made and you might wonder
why you might you might say well this
doesn't quite work or I'm not sure what
the motivation was
and the mailing list can sometimes give
you some view into the history of why
changes were made and some of the back
and forth there are actually two mailing
lists
there's Python dev and Python ideas
strictly Python ideas is supposed to be
the mailing list where you come up with
an idea
so something prior to the pet process
now you can think that and it's very
important in the Python community to be
very open to outsiders proposing ideas
even if maybe these are ideas that
you've seen before or considered already
Python ideas has a worse signal-to-noise
ratio than Python dev just because it is
the starting point for a lot of ideas
and as we know a lot of these ideas
aren't going to pan out so if you follow
both Python dev and Python ideas you're
gonna have a lot of daily reading to do
just to keep up to date so I think it's
a good reference once you want to
understand a change better but I don't
think it's a way that you can actually
keep up to date unless your job is to be
a Python expert at your organization but
if you're at that a scientist or some
kind of research scientist there's just
not a lot of value in spending your time
there another thing that you can do is
watch the bug tracker the core
contributors to some of the core
libraries actually pretty religiously
watch the bug tracker especially for
bugs that are relevant to them so the
Python bug tracker is public and let me
get online because I want to show you a
later show you one or two things from
the bug tracker
and a lot of the discussion around
features or fixes occurs on in the bug
tracker so let me open this up and I'll
show you and let me see if I can even
find see if I can find one that recently
got a little bit of a look through my
name okay so that would be it's my name
on it I don't actually follow this very
closely yeah give me one second - and
what was it dotted so one thing that I
had added a long yep here it is Tesla's
syntax this is one thing that I had
suggested if for a decorator in Python
you can't have anything but what's
called a dotted name so I still do
Python 3 so you can't do you can do if
you have some function like this you can
do this right as a decorator but you
can't do and you can do this X dot Y but
you can't do x dot y you it's not
generalized you can put any expression
behind the @ sign and the reason for
that is they just specifically
disallowed it so I put together a little
just as part of a presentation I was
giving I wanted to show people how to
report bugs on Python so as part of the
presentation I said well you know here's
here's my bug here's my bug report I
have a patch here's some information I
went through the mailing list to figure
out why that change was made and there
was some discussion and some people
actually really liked it and you can see
this was in 2013 and then very recently
somebody wanted to do something with
this in 2016 and you can see you know
there's some suggestion of this is very
useful and then Guido comes back and
says you know I don't think so then the
person comes back and says no this is
actually very useful for my library and
then there's a little bit of back and
forth and in the end it gets closed
because Guido says well I don't see any
real-world examples this is the
example of what happens on the bug
tracker list people have some
suggestions that might actually be
changes to the language but they first
say well this doesn't work or this
syntax isn't available or I wish I could
get this kind of behavior and they'll be
some of that public discussion mixed
between the mailing list and between the
bug tracker and you can watch post so
that if there's updates to them you'll
see them so the only reason I knew there
was an update to this is I got an email
but it's still a lot of volume for not a
lot of benefit that's another
possibility one great thing that you
could do is attend more PI data
conferences so I encouraged all of you
to consider giving a talk at a PI data
conference one thing that you might not
know about PI data conferences is a lot
of people who you might consider to be
accomplished and capable speakers got
their start speaking at PI data I don't
know if I would be included in that or
not but I did get my start speaking at
PI data conferences we very much like to
feature at these conferences people who
have never given talks before as an
opportunity for people to for
up-and-coming speakers to kind of get in
front of an audience and the easiest way
to give your very first talk is to talk
about something like what's new and
pandas because that information is all
online you can't really mess it up that
much you can speak to the core
developers of the tool and they'll tell
you they'll give you some feedback and
you can do something that will be
valuable for you because learning what's
new and pandas is going to be valuable
for you in your daily work and also be
valuable to the audience so that's
another way that you can keep up to date
you could check the what's the news
essays so every time there is a release
of Python there's one of these what's
new essays and they detail all the
changes this is probably one of the best
ways for you to keep up to date very
broadly in what's happening in Python
just because one of these is released
only with each made the major Python
version so you're looking at you know
one of these essays every couple of
every six months every year or so and
they're pretty comprehensive
they don't detail all the code changes
to Python so oftentimes there are very
very impactful code changes that are
happening just at the C Python level
that might not be covered by this this
is mostly things which Python
users my running to self Europe if you
manage some C extensions or your project
author yourself this may not go deeply
enough to cover all the things that you
care about but for most people you can
see it's a it's a pretty good resource
now if you look at this you'll see that
one of the sections is other language
changes here we go
you can see there's new features other
language changes new modules improved
modules it's pretty laid out pretty well
laid out for what you care about and
there's not a lot of content here or
there's not a lot of material that you
have to keep up-to-date with and it's
not updated that frequently so I think
that's actually one of the best tools to
use it is not however the tool that I
used when putting together the materials
for this talk the approach that I took
is to follow the peps all of the peps so
one thing that you might already know is
that all changes to the python language
have to go through a enhancement process
through an actual process PEP stands for
our python enhancement proposal and if
you go to github you can see repo with
all of the enhancement proposals for
python historically now you could star
this repo and check for any changes very
speculative changes won't be added to
the list of peps so that's one way to
filter out things that are very
speculative this changes very rarely so
you can see and where it changes where
people actually add peps is not a very
common thing so if you were looking at
just core language changes probably
following the peps is one one pretty
good way to do it and that's the way
that I put together this talk I looked
through all the peps and I tried to
extract the peps that were valuable or
useful for you one thing that a pet will
not contain is changes that are not
visible to changes that are not
immediately visible to a Python user so
for example there were there's an
environmental variable in Python 3:6
called pi malik or python malik and you
can set it to change what the memory
allocator for python is either to use
the internal Edith
Python memory allocator PI malloc or to
use a system memory allocator malloc and
to add debugging information there's no
pep for that change it wasn't considered
to be a language change but for a lot of
use cases if you were running in a
memory constrained environment as quite
a few people are that might actually be
very meaningful change something for you
to know about at the same time I'm
trying to think of an example of certain
certain other changes like rewriting
libraries famously the decimal library
was rewritten in Python 3 as a C
extension to be 80% faster so if you
want arbitrary precision decimal
arithmetic you can use a decimal library
and it's much much much faster than the
pure Python one that was written
previously that change wasn't ever made
in a pet because it didn't change any
functionality didn't add any features it
was just rewriting something that
already existed in a better fashion so
those kind of changes won't be visible
in the peps but they may still be very
useful a very valuable for you to know
about the way to keep up-to-date with
those as those what's changed essays
usually they they will indicate when
modules have changed when there are new
modules additionally if a module gained
a new function that won't be in a pep
it's too small of a change the peps are
for very large changes or generally for
very impactful changes I shower a from
the word large because you'll see from
some of these peps some of these aren't
that large in terms of what they do but
they do have an impact from a language
perspective on the code that you write
oh let me bring that back up so I
started with the peps and that was the
approach that I took for putting this
presentation together
so before I before we go through a bunch
of peps and if you're bored now boy when
we go through the peps I want to tell
you about the pet process pep one
details the entire pet process so it
details how you submit one what
information is required what the process
looks like I want to outline a couple of
important things from pep one notably
all language changes require a pep but
not all the changes that you're
interested in may come through the pet
process not all language changes are
approved by Guido van Rossum there is in
fact a delegate process that's been in
that's been in use for quite a few years
now what happens when a pep is proposed
one of the core contributors is allowed
to nominate him or herself as a delegate
for the be DFL subject matter expert and
authority in that area if that
nomination is accepted then that person
is able to decide where that pep goes
this happens a lot in areas where Guido
himself might not have enough experience
to be able to make a good judgment so
for example there are packaging B DFL
delegates there's people who routinely
help make decisions in terms of how
python is packaged people who routinely
help make decisions in terms of how
Python have things with security and
Python work typically for language
changes like features Guido Guido
handles those himself although when
Guido himself proposes a pet he
nominated he allowed somebody else to be
nominated to decide because he wanted
her to go through a reasonable process
where he wasn't rubber stamping his own
changes he wanted to have real feedback
additionally when you look at the peps
there's generally three types of pets
there's standard track peps
informational peps and procedural pets
process temps the standard tracks PAP
are what we what we're going to look at
and what we care about those are
generally new features or new
implementations in Python the
informational peps are just kind of
general guidelines so we're all familiar
with pep 8 pep 8 is an informational pep
they're they're useful to keep they're
useful to keep track of just because
these may detail best practices or deep
may detail things which are
important for you know about but they
won't detail language changes lastly
there are processed peps and they tend
to be about things which are outside of
language design so for example I believe
the move of Python from mercurial to get
to github was in a process pet and you
can think that's also something that
would be important to keep keep track of
wouldn't be in the what's new essay but
wouldn't be in one of the other two
types of peps will be in a process pet
the other important thing when you're
looking at the paps is to understand is
this something that I should care about
is this something I should look at and
the way to do that is to just understand
how the pet process works draft peps or
pep start off as drafts somebody who
writes up a draft and they say this is
an idea that I have those drafts can be
deferred if somebody says it's not quite
the right time if it's a horrible idea
it can be rejected outright if it's a
horrible idea and you don't want to be
publicly shamed by having it rejected
outright you can withdraw it if it's a
decent enough idea it will be accepted
but an accepted pet isn't necessarily
something that makes into the language
an accepted pet eventually becomes final
so the final pets are the things which
are guaranteed to have the language
unless there's some other pet repealing
it an accepted pet however can be later
rejected and so this is very important
because some of the changes some of the
pets that we'll look at are things which
are not yet in any codebase of Python
they've been accepted they will
eventually be and Python three six but
the patches haven't been put in haven't
been accepted into the into a trunk yet
and so it'll be a little bit difficult
for me to show you examples just because
I have to build a Python with all the
patches as well so let's follow the peps
what we can do is we can start by just
cloning the pepp repository and if we
clone the pepp repository we can see the
peps are just text files or just text
files in a very specific format and you
can see there are approximately 410 pets
that have ever been written
we want all the ones that are relevant
to Python 3 and to python 6 3 6 so what
we can do is we can just grep for those
pets and if we look through this we can
see these are all the pets that are
relevant to Python 3 5 or 3 6 and
there's quite a few than this 42 of them
that are relevant now I'm only looking
at ones which are which have a listed
Python version and which have a status
of accepted draft will have any of the
statuses we looked at before of course
we really only care about the ones which
are accepted rejected withdrawn or final
so if we filter down to those we can see
it's a much smaller list some of them
were deferred and some of them were
withdrawn and we don't really care about
changes which people said well this is
probably a bad idea either to do now or
to do ever and in fact we probably only
care about the accepted peps and the
final pimp's things which are likely to
make it into the language and things
which are definitely going to be in the
language we'd probably don't care about
the rejected or they're withdrawn pips
so these are this is what's remaining
this list is just the accepted in the
final pets that are marked for Python 3
and 6 and in this list I'll go through
only a couple of them so this is a list
of all the pets that we could talk about
I'm gonna skip a couple of them these
are the ones that I'm going to go
through pet 448 well you can see the
list here and we'll go through them
right now so pet 448 additional
unpacking generalizations this is status
final so this will be in the language
this is for Python 3 5 so this is
already available for a lot of you to
use let's take a look at what that is
you may be familiar with a pet 3 1 3 2
pep 3 1 3 2 gave you extended iterable
unpacking I'll show you what that means
we can we can unpack things like that we
can unpack any any iterable with a
simple assignment syntax by just having
comma separated variable names on the
left hand side and then the values on
the right hand side but we had to match
up the exact number we have to
structurally match up the exact number
and structure on the left hand side as a
right hand side so for example let's
start a Python 2
here's a Python two-terminal I can't do
this because I have too few values on
the right hand I have too few values on
the left hand side for the values on the
right hand side and I can't do this I
have too many values on the left hand
side for the right hand side extended
iterable unpacking said well we can use
the same star unpacking syntax in order
to capture the case where maybe we don't
know how many things there are on the
right hand side and so what I can do in
Python 3 and just a stock Python 3 just
the Python 3 that comes with my computer
I can now do X Y Z equals 1 2 3 4 5 6
and all of these additional values will
be captured in Z as a list and those two
values will be captured and I can and
it's actually very flexible syntax
because you can see I can put that star
anywhere and so this means there's some
value I could do more sophisticated on
destructuring this is some value than
any number of values and then one tail
value so I can do something if any of
you are old list programmers this might
start to look kind of like car and
cutter where I can get the head of a
list and the rest of the list we could
do those kind of d structuring x' one
thing that we can't do because it would
be ambiguous is put two stars there it
would be ambiguous to determine which of
which of those two variables X or rather
Y or Z would take the remaining items so
that's a pep that was already accepted
if you look at that pep which we'll do
we can see that it was actually marked
as standards track for Python 3 in 2007
so that feature has been around for a
very long time for you the pep that
we're looking at right now adds more
generalized unpacking capabilities so
let's go back to Python 2 in Python 2 we
might have a function that takes any
number of arguments and we might just
print out what those arguments are and
we can pass it arguments directly like
this or we could pass it unpacked
arguments like that
but we can't do a double unpacking and
we can't pass it arguments like that in
an argument the end there's some syntax
limitations that were that in Python 2
just to reduce ambiguity and just
because these weren't considered to be
completely generalized in Python 3 5 we
can now generalize the use of the star
and the use of the star star for tuple
and keyword unpacking or for regular
impact for sequence and keyword
unpacking in any expression context so
the first thing that allows us to do is
say we have a function here f that takes
multiple arguments we can now pass it
many things to unpack and it does what
you expect at first unpacks that 1 2 3 &
2 positional arguments then it unpacks
that 4 5 6 into positional arguments I
can give it single positional arguments
and then I can unpack more stuff here
and you can see it does exactly what you
into it that could be useful that could
definitely be useful however the purpose
of this PAP is to really generalize the
use of the star and the star star so in
any expression context where it makes
sense for you to unpack a sequence or
unpack a key word you can now do that so
what I can also do is here I can create
a tuple with 3 values right I might call
this people X I might want to create
another tuple Y that is the values of X
plus some other values and this is how I
would have done this in Python in Python
2 in Python 3 I could just say it's X
unpacked plus a 4 or 5 and a 6 there we
go so we can see the use of this star
unpacking has been completely
generalized the unpacking is not quite
as flexible I don't know if any of you
have played with Java Script recently
but I think es6 has some really fancy
structure unpacking that works really
nicely for that language the D
structuring and Python 3 5 is
generalized but it's not quite as
flexible it doesn't have all the
features of that but it's in the same
vein it's a very useful thing to do you
can make some you can
right some things a lot more tersely now
one of the motivations I see for this
pet was there was always this question
of I have two dictionaries and how do I
merge two dictionaries how do I merge
these and some people would say I'll
create a new dictionary and then do X
dot update or rather Z update of X and
said that update of Y and you could
merge them like that or other syntaxes
that might be more that no might be
tercer than this you could do kV for kV
in X dot items wide on items you can do
like this
into um you could do something like that
as well but you can think with the
generalized unpacking now you can just
say I want a dictionary and I want a
keyword unpack the values of X and
keyword unpack the values of Y until you
can now merge dictionaries very nicely
with a very simple syntax this is I
think one of the you can think that for
for normal tuple unpacking one of the
motivations for that is just a really
nice they're really nice and very
concise format for swapping two
variables you could think that maybe
this dictionary unpacking is its
equivalent this motivating feature now
what you can see from the examples on
the screen is that you can you can use
this at any expression context so I can
now create a list if I have a list of
values I can create another list that's
just those values unpacked and then some
other values here any context in which
it makes sense for me to unpack I can
now use that star impact or that star
star unpacking similarly you can you can
mix and match these to your heart's
desire but I think the idea should be
fairly clear so let's take a look at our
next step there's quite a few of these
to go through 465 now I wanted to when
choosing which peps to look at I wanted
to skip some of the peps that would take
a very long time to look at and also
wouldn't be that interesting for this
audience one of those peps was the type
in ting the type in ting is I feel it's
a very speculative pet just because it
it outlines a syntax for tools that
aren't quite using it yet type in ting
there aren't that many tools that are
using the type ending support just yet
so it's still in a fairly speculative
place I wanted to skip other pets that
were probably already well known to you
this is one that might already be
well-known too but I think it's
something very major not for what it
does but for why it was introduced so as
you might know in numpy you know we have
two array objects and if we multiply
those two array objects we're gonna do
an element-wise multiplication so here
even though I'm trying to multiply X
times
identity matrix I get elementwise
multiplication and I should get X back
out but I don't it just multiplies each
value well the reason for that is numpy
deals with arrays not matrices so it
doesn't really know that you want to do
a matrix multiplication operation all of
the arithmetic operations that it
performs are assumed to be element wise
now historically the way around that was
to explicitly tell numpy that these are
matrix types which would then cause the
multiplication operation to perform
matrix multiplication so you can see
here if I do that you can see I
multiplied X times identity matrix and I
got X back out except this becomes very
clumsy because often times you want to
deal with numpy arrays you don't wanna
have to wrap them in this matrix type
and sometimes you want to do element
wise multiplication and sometimes you
want to do matrix multiplication other
languages introduce sets of operators so
I believe in R you have dot and then the
operator and then the operator by itself
to distinguish between element wise and
not element wise operations I'm not sure
if that's correct I'm not much of an art
programmer in Python it was identified
that at least this was one area where
you know things were getting kind of
ugly so in Python 35 a new operator was
added the commercial act and that
indicates matrix multiplication now
there are a couple of things I wanted to
say one the @ sign doesn't really mean
matrix multiplication the @ sign means
invoke a protocol called mat mol so the
protocol very heavily suggests matrix
multiplication that said what actually
does the matrix multiplication is how
this protocol was implemented in numpy
what that means is if you wanted to
create any number of really horrible
api's using an @ symbol you're free to
do that now it's just a new operator
that you're able to overload in addition
to plus minus divide you now have the
app operator which I'm sure you can
already think of some terrible email
related or who knows what Twitter
related you could do like tweet at
somebody and maybe that sends off a
tweet who knows you do some really
terrible
with this operator the reason I wanted
to repeat or the reason I wanted to
bring this operator to your attention
again is that I think it marks a very
meaningful change in the development of
the Python language everybody here is a
data scientist and you all represent in
my estimation a good probably third to
greater than third of the Python
community the Python community has if
you wanted to just very easily divide it
into three groups there are all the web
programmers out there using tools like
Jango and flask there are all the system
programmers out there who are writing
tools like apt or you know shuffling
data from one side of an organization to
another or building automation or
testing frameworks and then there's the
data science people historically if you
look at a conference like Python that
was held a couple months back in
Portland almost all the talks were
people talking about system stuff or
people talking about web stuff in the
last two years I went to some hard work
by some of the volunteers from the
project Jupiter organization more talks
on data science were included in Python
and I think this past Python was one
third data science talks what this means
is the core developers for the Python
community none of whom come from a data
science background are beginning to
better understand that there are a lot
of users out there who are scientific
users who want this language for
scientific use and they're beginning to
understand that in order for in order
for them to make these users happy they
need to recognize the needs of those
users I see this pep if I wanted to it's
a little physio but I would say that I
see this pepper as a symbolic move to
say ok we're recognizing the needs of
data science users of scientific users
where previously we had mostly been
focusing on the needs of systems users
and web programming users and I think
that we're going to see many more peps
and many more changes to the language in
the future that make it easier for you
to use data science tools than we saw
him past and so that's why I wanted to
bring up this pepper I think it's
something that's very meaningful because
if you ever have a
to see guido at PyCon and talked to him
you'll see he really doesn't know a lot
about what we do here at a PI data event
we actually invited him to speak at this
event but he had a family trip but he
was actually very interested in speaking
this event and I think one of the things
that he could have brought to you is
just talking about how a lot of the core
developers don't come from the same
background at all if you come from they
don't have that exposure to the needs of
scientific code whether in research or
an industry and how they've had to
integrate that into you know how that
how the Python community works how the
core development community works let's
move on and let's talk about pet 485 a
function for testing approximate
equality this is one thing which you
might say I shouldn't editorialize too
much for all these pets one thing that I
think you'll see in the pet process is
that one clear focus of the developers
of the Python language is to make it a
friendly language for newbies to use and
so I think that 45 I would see that more
as a tool to make it clear and obvious
for people who aren't professional
programmers to use Python I'll show you
what it does and then I'll tell you what
we know that if we take two numbers 11
and 22 that's equal to we sum them
that's equal to 33 but if we do 1.1 plus
2.2 it's not equal to 3.3 we might
wonder why that is and we might actually
say okay well if we look at one point
one plus two point two this is done an I
Triple E 754 floating point mathematics
there's some imprecision and that's the
result that we get in fact if we do
point one plus point two and we take the
result and we paste it into our location
bar and put a dot-com at the end you get
a really neat website that tells you how
floating point math is handled in all
different languages and tells you a
little bit about why this happens this
leads to you can think for a lot of
people who aren't who aren't longtime
programmers this can lead to some
consternation because you know they
might see an expression they might say
well I'm adding these two numbers or
comparing these two floating-point
numbers and I should compare is equal
but there's a problem because maybe one
of the numbers is supposed to be zero
but it's actually 1 times 10 to the
negative 16th it's very close to but not
exactly zero in fact this happens more
often than you'd like with even core
library so if I do from math import sign
and do the sine of PI the sine of Pi is
not 0 in Python it's just very close to
zero and so if I were some scientific
user who didn't have in the forefront of
my mind oh this is I Triple E 754 and
there's floating you know there's error
I might write code like that and it
wouldn't do what I expect so what the
Python developers or what the pepp does
is it adds an extra function to the math
module to called is close so that you
can determine if two numbers are close
so here you can see is 1.1 plus 2.2
close to 3.3 it's supposed to be and
this is something that you would have
done yourself just by saying 1.1 plus
2.2 absolute value of this minus this
less than something you would have done
this threshold checking yourself but it
gives you you know a standardized single
place to do that threshold checking that
should be something obvious for newbies
one motivation that you'll see in the
pet process for things being accepted is
that in many cases the Python core
developers look at how code is used in
the wild so they'll do Google searches
there used to be a really nice part of
the Google website where you could do
searches through code bases but they'll
try and do searches through github or
through publicly available code for
patterns and see if people are using
patterns that they're trying to do
better the other thing they'll do is
they'll grep they'll Google for how do I
do XYZ in Python and they'll see what
Stack Overflow or what one of the
question answer sites suggests and
sometimes those answers aren't very good
and if those answers aren't very good or
aren't very obvious they'll say well
this is something that needs to be fixed
about the language because you can
imagine how for all of us professional
capables super sophisticated Python
users how many users out there are using
it just as a tool and they run into a
problem and the first thing they're
gonna do is Google for it look on Stack
Overflow
and then
stackoverflow and then they need the
obvious answer to be they need the
answer to be obvious and clear and so by
changing the language they can motivate
that better so this is one example I
think of that is close of course takes
gives you the ability to do with a
relative tolerance so here we can see as
ninety close to ninety ninety point one
with a relative tolerance of zero but an
absolute tolerance of 0.1 so this says
is ninety within point one of ninety
point one and that's true and here you
can also do with the relative tolerance
is ninety within one per one sorry ten
percent of ninety five and that's true
so you can do both relative and absolute
threshold checking with just one
function and so if you have anybody ask
you that question or if you were to
Google for that question hopefully the
top answer on Stack Overflow would say
just use this function and eliminate a
lot of back-and-forth a lot of
consternation of people who aren't
intimately familiar with the nuances of
floating-point arithmetic might run into
let's take a look at pep 487 simpler
customize customization of class
creation this one is really obscure so
this is actually an accepted pep so you
can see this one is status final this
pep was actually there were two peps
talking about simple about simplifying
class customization one of them was
withdrawn pep for twenty two and it was
withdrawn because the pep that I'm about
to show you does a better job of the
topic that we're looking at so you know
we might all use some we might use some
tool from some library like some class
so imagine there's some library and has
a class a and there's a class B and
unknown to us there's some need to
customize the creation of those classes
there's some need for a medic lass and
so a hasn't met a class of B as a medic
class and that's not necessarily a
detail that we would know about or care
about it might not even be visible in
the documentation for these two
libraries you might just see Class A and
Class B and the metaclass might be
considered to be part of the
implementation and so not part of the
public API
what you're gonna do is you might want
to have a Class C that inherits from
both a and B and unfortunately there's
really no nice mechanism for doing this
while remaining ignorance of a and B
having metaclasses
because if you try and inherit from a
and B and notice a and B are not fancy
classes they don't do anything and
they're metaclasses don't really do
anything either except print out a
message to the screen but when you try
and inherit from a and B you run into a
metaclass conflict the reason for that
is in constructing the C class we have
to determine what metaclass is being
used we look through all the base
classes all the base classes you need
the most derived meta class and if the
base class is metaclasses derive from
different hierarchies there's no way to
reconcile that you can't tell which of
the two metaclasses to use consider that
a meta class essentially is any code
that can do anything that you want to
customize the creation of a class within
some fairly limited constraints or some
fairly actually not that one minute
constraints but within some constraints
and so there's no way that generalize
the merging of two meta classes or to
decide which of those two meta classes
is more senior to the other other than
some nominal mechanism for indicating
that one is more derived than the other
more fundamentally we want to write our
own subclasses and we want to subclass
things and libraries and library authors
want to use meta classes to do their
work
that's a nice it's a nice way to
implement a lot of the functionality
they want to provide to us and but they
don't want us to have to bear the
knowledge of how that implementation
works and so this is a giant wart what
was identified is that most of the
before I show you the change most of the
cases where people who are using meta
classes fell into about three categories
the first one was you create a subclass
and you do a couple things to the
methods of that subclass the second one
was you need to know the exact order in
which the attributes in the subclass
were defined so think for an enum if you
wanted to create an enum and you wanted
to automatically number that you
automatically number the elements for
the constants you want to have new
numerical value equal to the symbolic
value you wanted to have that number
work automatically you'd have to know
the exact ordering but that's not
available because the metaclass gets a
dictionary of all the class contents and
since dictionaries aren't ordered you
you have no way to know the actual
ordering of the things inside the
metaclass this is why in Python 3 for I
believe they added prepare as a
underscore method to metaclasses so that
you can tell your meta class what the
dictionary subclasses should use for
building the contents of the class and
that's how they were able to implement
the enumerated type that said so I said
there were three things I have to do the
third one is calling specific methods on
attributes of the class so I'll show you
what this pepp does what it does is it
tries to create a simpler set of
protocols in C Python for changing how
classes work there are less flexible
than meta classes may be more
understandable to a general audience
more tractable and also allow for easier
merging when you want to do multiple
inheritance with two classes that have
this functionality enabled so let's talk
about the first thing so one thing that
people might want to do is they want to
control class creation so for example
one example I can give you is I worked
in an environment once where we were
using a unit test and in unit test has a
setup and a teardown method and in the
setup method we all have to we all have
to call a very specific method in that
setup method in order to initialize a
testing database and if you didn't call
that method your unit tests wouldn't
work there were two proposed solutions
to go through our many thousands of
lines of unit test to make sure that
happened one of them was that just grep
for cases where people didn't write the
unit test correctly and send the minimo
and have a job that sat behind the
scenes grepping you know every day and
then sending nasty emails to people the
other one that I proposed was you write
a ten line metaclass so that every time
you create a unit test when that unit
tests class is created it automatically
does the behavior that you want so
you're guaranteed that all the methods
in the setup method would definitely be
called very easy to do with a very
simple medic class what that medic class
does is it says all subclasses of this
type have a certain requirement one easy
way to think about metaclasses is it's a
way for you to have a guarantee enforced
from a base class down to a sub class as
opposed to the other way around so for a
base class to say if you're gonna derive
from me you have to do these things and
the reason you have to do these things
is because when you are created I'll
have a hook into your creation code to
force you to do certain things that
Cooke was added explicitly as in its
subclass so here we have a base class
and a derived class and when we run this
code in our Python 3 6 this is only a
Python 3 6 feature so I have to bring up
a Python 3 6 Python interpreter which I
source compiled one thing that I wanted
to do for you is show you how to install
Python 3 6 in anaconda there is a
channel that there is a condo channel
that provides Python 3 6 but I couldn't
get it to install so I had to build
everything from source but what you can
see is I have a base class and a derived
class and if I stick this in my Python
interpreter here let me do the base
class first every time I try I create I
try to create a derived class from this
it'll call this special code I'll say
somebody's trying to derive for me now
we need to do this in actually we can't
do this in Python 3 6 this is the Python
3 6 that's on the Python website it's
not the codes not even there yet the
codes in only to get depository so I
have to do that one more time
here we go so here we go so every time I
try and create a derived class you can
see it's calling that callback and that
callback allows you to then customize
the creation of this class so you can
think metaclasses are used for things
like abstract base classes enforcing
that abstract methods are implemented
you could use that within its subclass
because in its subclass has the ability
to call a super method then you can
think that the danger in this kind of
meta class conflict is eliminated it's
no
more dangerous to use in its subclass as
it is to create your own earn it if you
forget to call super that's your own
fault and using the linearization the
method called linearization super will
call the units of classes in the right
order so that's one of the pieces the
next piece
so that's an example the next piece is a
function called set name so when you
create a class let me create a let me
create a data item and I'll define set
name and I'll just print out
whoops and it doesn't have to return you
think so now when I create a class if I
have any of these here in the class like
consider this is a very common pattern
for descriptors that set name will be
called so what you can do is you can
trigger code on the descriptors that are
created for your classes this is another
common thing that's done so this is an
on every instantiation of the class it's
on or rather every instantiation of a
instance of the class it's on the
instantiation of the class object of
type object itself so it's a callback
that gives you a hook into that so
that's what that does and then lastly
the last part of giving you the
definition order is provided by separate
pep-pep 520 what pepp 520 does is it
gives you an underscore item on a class
that gives you the original order in
which things were defined so I'll show
you what the current case is the current
case is that if I create a class foo and
I have a B and C if I look at the dict
for foo or if I look at the juror of foo
I get the I get the elements but I don't
necessarily get them in any specific
order coincidentally these are in the
order ABC but really there's no ordering
guarantee here so I wouldn't know the
order in which these were laid out it
was considered that and this is a fairly
major change to Python although it
doesn't affect a lot of user code but it
was thought that the order on which you
define things in a class body in Python
is very much intentional and so
retaining that order is very important
and so they added definition order to
get the actual order in which things
were defined this greatly simplifies the
creation of things like enumerated types
that's that change this is a very big
change that I want to really quickly
gloss over with two examples pet for 92
co-routines with async and await syntax
so who here is using some kind of async
i/o library whether async i/o itself or
one of the user supported versions not a
lot of people and that's not too
uncommon most scientific users are
if we were to talk about the performance
approaches that most scientific users
use the first one is not using pure
Python using numpy the second one would
be using C extensions the third one
would be using scythe on or maybe scythe
on and then C extensions the fourth one
might be looking into tools like desk or
some of the large frameworks that you'll
see presented at this event and it's
fairly rare that for scientific tasks
you'll look at things like async i/o
just because for many of your problems
their CPU bound and not IO bound but you
can imagine some problems that you're
dealing with our i/o bound and in the
world of web programmers and system
programmers a lot of their problems are
i/o bound and so because they're not
waiting for CPU cycles are just waiting
for network requests to respond it's
very helpful for them to have good
syntax to handle asynchronous i/o what
that means is and I'll show you two
examples from two blogs and the
references the links are at the top of
the examples this is from this is via a
really nice blog post by Brett cannon
via a tutorial on async IO here we have
a fairly simple example of a countdown a
co-routine what it does is it prints out
something and then it sleeps for one
second when it sleeps because this
generator has the ability to yield
execution back to the caller it yields
execution back to the caller which in
this case is the event loop so you have
some event loop that can go through all
the processes and say are you ready to
do something if you are run otherwise go
to the next one if you are run and so on
and so you can have multiple tasks
running simultaneously only waking up
when they're ready to do something
namely when they're ready because some
operating system mechanism like a poll
has said there's i/o that's ready to be
read off socket or something like that
and so without using threading which has
problems related to the G il or
multi-processing which has problems
related to the ability to share data we
can now write code that at least for i/o
bound problems doesn't block on slow i/o
operations
of the most exciting things to come out
of this I think is there's a new post
quest library that uses the async i/o
tools that is very fast it's fairly new
but it's very fast
it's very pythonic and it's something
that i've personally been very excited
to use in my day to day work so this is
what it used to look like so this is not
what the pep does this is a think I know
when it came out in Python 3 for a lot
of patterns were seen in the usage of
async i/o where we were using decorators
like this to create these co-routine
objects to take normal generators and to
indicate that they were actually used
for async i/o and so specific syntax was
introduced in Python 3 5 in order to
make this easier and so this is where
you see this async def async def and
this oh wait I really wish I had more
time to go into this in greater depth
there should be an async i/o and async
await talk if not at this event will do
something in the BOF room because I
think it's a topic that's worth putting
a solid hour of information to so if
that's something that you're interested
please let me know and we'll set up a
BOF session tomorrow with one of the
developers of this tool actually with
one of the core developers who and we'll
go we'll go through this and in a lot of
depths so I apologize for glossing over
that pept three not four not four ninety
five one thing about this pep that you
can see is that peps are always that
major pet for 95 merely adds a single
attribute to daytime objects called dot
fold to represent when to daytime
objects represent the same actual time
when two distinct times represent the
same actual time so think daylight
savings you know on march 13th you roll
your clock back of 2 a.m. or you roll it
forward at 2 a.m. and so you have 2
physical times that represent the same
time they're full of the time all it
does is it adds a single attribute to
the day time want to the day time object
that's set to 0 or 1 on whether this is
a fold of time so peps aren't always big
major things sometimes they can be you
know fairly small things but in a case
like this it's something that required a
lot of discussion and a lot of
deliberation and had some real effects
for people who are doing things
who are getting into the nitty-gritty of
daytime library pipet 498 this one
actually ended up being much more
controversial than you think so you know
when I started with Python we had this
style of doing string interpolation we
used these kind of printf style percent
formats so here I'm printing out the
number 10 as a floating-point number
with two decimal points of precision and
then the so-called advance string
formatting came along so we have these
curly braces technique since the
technique that I use and that's some
nice things where you can pass rich
objects and then create your own set of
formatting parameters so that you can
instead of passing strings around in
your code path rich objects and have the
templates decide what parts of the rich
object to extract so here you can see
I'm printing out the date but I'm not
passing that part of the data they're
not calling some string F time function
I'm passing the date object itself and
the templates deciding what parts of the
data object to use which is very useful
because the template knows more about
the visual representation of this
information than the code that's being
inserted into the template one other
thing that I didn't add here is in the
string module there is a template
function I don't know if anybody uses
that I've never used that and I haven't
really seen it used so I skipped it what
this pep what this pep does is
identifies that actually what this pep
does is identifies that oftentimes we
want to do something looks like this we
want to create a string using some local
variables and there's some limitations
this first to do it this way it's kind
of ugly
we know there's this function locals
that create that gives us a dictionary
of all local variables and we could
keyword unpack it and we could use named
arguments in our advanced string
formatting but this is a little ugly to
do it's a little bit clumsy and there
are some real limitations to this
approach because locals will not contain
variables that exist only in the closure
so you have to end up forcing that to be
recognized as a local variable and it
gets kind of clumsy for what is a very
simple thing that people want they want
to be able to do a kind of string
formatting that we're familiar with from
using bash
Ruby or I think even pearl a lot of
other languages that make this available
you want to create a string and you want
to have placeholders for variable names
and you want it to just interpolate that
automatically so if strings were added
to Python an F string is just a string
we're inside the curly braces you have
any arbitrary expression this is
actually kind of interesting because it
can be any arbitrary expression outside
of so any expression so no syntax but
actually I'm kind of curious what you
can do
so obviously where this is intended to
be used is like this yeah I gave my X&Y
but there's no reason you can't do this
right I wonder if you can do this
now let me do this I wonder if you can
put a string I don't think you can oh
that's really horrible so now your
strings can contain any arbitrary
executable code including calling
modules so there are oftentimes
unintended consequences for some of
these peps so now just be careful oh and
here's the neat thing let's let's figure
out what's - let me show you something
but I wanted to know I need to do it
like this
so one one important thing though is
this evaluation is or this is evaluated
at actually no yeah this is evaluated at
string creation time so it's not gonna
be the case that you print out a string
and that it's probably not gonna be the
case you print out a string and
somebody's added some executable to that
code to that string and suddenly all
hell breaks loose because the evaluation
order of this you still have string
literals and you do have some
expressions in them but at the string
evaluation time whether that's in a
nested scope or in the top-level scope
is where is when the expression will be
evaluated so thankfully you're not going
to take some user input and suddenly
that user input is gonna call arbitrary
functions on your code that would be a
nightmare so there are some limitations
of that but that's what the f string
format is and it's something that's been
added there has been a lot of discussion
on the mailing list about other letters
to put in front of strings other types
of ways to do string interpolation but
this is the only one that's made it
through the pet process so far and you
can see for simple uses like x and y
it's pretty good maybe for something
like X 2 plus 2 that might be useful for
some of the for putting arbitrary
expressions inside of your a string
template that may not be so useful but
you can think one thing that you could
only one thing that you can think III I
don't want to say this is not that
useful or I don't want to I don't want
to disparage this feature because you
could say here I have some templated
string and maybe I want to do the length
of the templated string to figure out
you know plus 3 to figure out some
formatting to align it nicely and I
could do something like that so let's
I don't know so let's continue
5:06 adding a secrets module to the
standard library so when people need to
do things with cryptographic secrets
they oftentimes will just Google for how
do I do such adults how do I create a
password how do I create a token in
Python 3 and Stack Overflow posts show
many different approaches a lot of the
approaches that you'll find on Stack
Overflow and blogs don't necessarily use
the cryptographically secure primitives
in the Python standard library what I'll
tell you is a Python standard library
contains primitives that are safe for
you to use and cryptographic app
applications that said it's not always
obvious where they are or which ones
they are there is a random module and a
random module contains a lot of things
and it's not obvious is this safe to use
or not there is a desire to add a new
module in the standard library called
secrets which is an obvious place for
things which are cryptographically
strong so that when somebody asks how do
i generate a random token and I wanted
to be cryptographically strong or how do
I can how do I compare two byte strings
and I wanted to be resistant to timing
attacks I wanted to take exactly the
same amount of time irrespective of
where they differ the secrets module
contains that and so it's supposed to be
just like in the case of the previous
back that's supposed to be something
that's very obvious for people to direct
especially users who are not already
experts in this field to the right place
to it so this module is intended to
contain functions for creating session
keys it'll contain interfaces to the
cryptographically secure parts of the
random module so a way to cryptographic
enact a secure fashion randomly choose
something randomly derive sets of bits
randomly generate numbers from 0 on the
open from 0 up to some value so
basically a Rand wrench from 0 up to
some X and to do things like timing
attack resistant string comparison and
byte comparison let's take a look at
pipette 515 maybe so there's no code for
this pet so I can't show this to you in
practice it hasn't been added to Python
core there's just patches but this may
be probably the only pet that you're
really then you might be really excite
about using if you have a number like
this I don't think any of you can tell
me within about a second of time whether
this is 12 million or 1.2 million now
you can add underscores that separate
the digits that really really I think
that's a this is one of my favorite peps
out of the whole list this really helps
Steven is there question
Oh climate so you can see peps don't
always have to be big things but they
can actually really help you out and
they can this is something that could
really if you if you knew about this and
you were able to use this in your Python
version you're using Python 3 6 and the
code was available this could really
help you improve your code and also if
you saw this as code you might wonder
what's going on here and having just
some very broad understanding of the pet
process and what peps are available you
might look at this and say oh yeah this
is just this pet Berra mind I sound like
I'm very knowledgeable just because I've
actually prepared materials for this and
so I know the names of all the pets I
don't actually know the names of the
peps outside of this presentation I just
know them because I put together these
materials so don't worry if you don't
know that pet for 48 is I was talking
about like a minute ago I can't remember
which one that was so don't worry about
that just be aware that these pets do
exist and that there was some discussion
and then that is your resource for
official version or an official
description of the motivation behind the
problem the solution and discussions
around the implementation pep 5:19 was
adding a system pack protocol this is a
very very small pep in pep 428 the path
Lib module was added to Python the idea
was people are storing system paths as
strings but we want to have a rich
object for storing these so in Python 3
you can already do this you there's a
module called path lab you can create
rich path objects you can use this
debatably elegant syntax to concatenate
paths so here i'm creating a path to
user and a path to lib the thing is all
of the places you want to put a path
like a open function to open a file they
don't take where chopsticks they take
strings and think about all the api's
that still take pass the string objects
not as rich objects well that's one of
the big barriers to using rich path
object so a new protocol was added
called FS path an emphasis path is just
another underscore function that you can
define that gets called when a part of
the standard library or part of some
library that needs a path is a string
needs to get a string equivalent so what
you can think is if you're creating your
own path objects or you're using the
path lip you can now use it safely with
functions that need string paths or
strings or sequences of bytes if the
author of those has implemented this
protocol you can now use Ridge path
objects that's really all it is for this
is one of the last peps that I'm going
to talk about and it also shows you one
more thing about the pet process it was
the addition of math tau this is
accepted it's in Python 3.6 but the code
is still in patched for him so I won't
show it to you but it doesn't do too
much now bug 1 2 3 4 5 on the Python bug
tracker was created by a very nice guy
who we haven't yet gotten to speak at a
PI data event Nick Coughlin and some of
you may be familiar about the Tau
manifesto the idea that if PI you know
looks like that tau is just one of them
and a lot of formulas like the surface
area of a sphere much simpler if you
talk about not pi but pi over 2 if you
look at this at this bug track and the
reason I wanted to show you the bug
tracker is that this is where a lot of a
discussion of this happens there are
some people like Erin Muir the
aforementioned core developer for sin pi
who says you know it's cute but nobody
in the sciences really ever uses that
nobody in mathematics really uses tau
it's not something that's very useful
and in fact instead we want something
like I think he wants Oyler gamma added
to the math module I say no don't but
this was added as a joke now this was
this pet this bug report was added it
was added as a joke by Nick in 2011 and
you know some people took it seriously
some people were just kind of jokingly
and then very recently I believe on
Nick's birthday itself Guido said where
does he say it
so right before the arguments against it
I'm just gonna do this so it got
accepted so in in future builds of
Python you'll be able to use both PI and
tau the argument for that there's a very
nice discussion of why this is not a
good idea by Raymond who may be at this
event this weekend where nobody does it
he's never seen this in production
adding mysteriously named Constance
describes dis grades degrades the
usability of it
I can survey the audiences at the
upcoming SF high data conference to see
if any of the participants have any clue
what this is about and Guido says great
I agree with your arguments I agree with
you
you
there
in ten years from home by the way